foreign secretary what will your message
to the russians be today sir
what a moment to be britain's new
foreign secretary james cleverly
arriving for a special security council
session as new atrocities emerge from
ukraine and russia's president threatens
nuclear war in the chamber the floor was
given first to the prosecutor for the
international criminal court
picture that i've seen so far is
troubling indeed
destruction
of suffering
and harm
that 14 fortifies my determination
and my previous finding that there are
reasonable grounds to believe that
crimes within the jurisdiction of the
court
have been committed
this is what his teams have seen in the
past week
this is isiam from where the russians
recently retreated
mass graves filmed by sky news bodies
exhumed by investigators
and signs of horrific deaths
but from the russians the continued
narrative of denial is an attempt today
to impose on us a completely different
narrative about russian aggression as
the origin
of
all the tragedy
this ignores the fact that for over
eight years the ukrainian army and
fighters from the nationalist formations
killed and continued to kill
inhabitants of dunbas with impunity but
he didn't have time to listen to the
rest of the speakers he walked out off
camera as britain took to the floor
he has left the chamber
i'm not surprised i don't think mr
lavrov wants to hear
the collective condemnation
of this council the foreign secretary
quoted from the testimony of a ukrainian
wife and mother
my husband was left for hours
lying on the floor in the pool of his
blood
i don't know why
we'd done nothing wrong
then they took my son away from us i
don't know where i don't know if we'll
ever see him again i just want my boy
back
but this chamber has heard these sorts
of stories before what can this
institution do because russia has a
permanent seat it has the power of veto
have you got no teeth as a consequence
well what we have seen today
is that there is a unanimity of
condemnation of russia's actions the
chinese and the indians have voiced
concerns and their unease is significant
they're russia's allies
but here's the split they want an
immediate ceasefire now that would leave
large parts of ukraine in russia's hands
and for many countries in there that is
unacceptable
and so the impasse the suffering and the
extraordinary nuclear rhetoric continues
mark stones guy news at the un in new
york